[Music]
good morning John it's Friday May 25th
free monkey and I are about to go out on
the town this is what free monkey has
mostly been doing since he's been here
become kind of friends with the cat I
just put him there and she goes up and
they sit together free monkey but now
free monkeys going out of the town we're
gonna stop by a couple of places and
then we're gonna hike up to the M this
is where we're going buddy
first stop the zilla's carousel at
Harris Park it looks pretty secure on
there
we will be right
very best
my monkey is taking a swing out free
monkey and I are getting a haircut
my friend whines monkey and she's
publishing a book and he's going on tour
before her book so my enemy into two
words um yes your hands will be anyways
a couple of little hairs
[Music]
and then free monkey and I achieved our
goal we hiked and hiked a hiked until he
got to Missoula Montana zem and then
free monkey sat and gazed upon the city
of Missoula where will free monkey go
next and here's my haircut puffs levels
are lower it was a fun day
in celebration of free monkeys excellent
day today and all of John's Holland
happy dances and also because the period
of collection for Randy's family has
ended the worldsuck index has decreased
to suck level yellow immediately
elevated it's a great day in the history
of worldsuck the first time that the
world suck meter has ever been in
anything besides severe it's kind of
hard to celebrate when a period of
mourning ends nobody celebrate from the
flag goes up from half-mast after a
national disaster yeah we don't have to
mourn anymore you can't really celebrate
that thinking about that got me thinking
about the period of time after a
presidents death when we all have the
flags at half-mast and we mourn I think
about that got me thinking about how
weird that is going to be when I'm
mourning the death of George Bush
thinking about that made me realize that
since I am so much younger than George
Bush chances are I will live to see the
day when he dies thinking about that
actually kind of made me a little happy
and then first thing about that kind of
made me a little bit ashamed then I
realized that it's not because he'd be
dead or because someone would be dying
or because I want him to die because a
part of me suddenly realized that
there's a lot of future yet to come and
then I'm gonna be around to see you on
of that future thinking about that
actually kind of made me pretty hopeful
I'll see you on Monday